bonjour mademoiselle bonjour messieurs
quelles que puissent être les
divergences ce qui l'emportent et de
loin c'est ce qui nous rapproche est
ainsi je pense que l'on peut résumer le
télégramme que c'est lui le président
pompidou a dressé de l'avion qui le
ramenait vers paris au président des
états unis richard knicks quelques
puissent être les divergences ce qui
l'emporté de loin
c'est ce qui nous rapproche vous voyez
que le président de la république semble
ne pas vouloir tenir contre désormais
comme il l'a fait dans ces présentes
déclarations des quelques incidents qui
n'ont plus marqué son voyage notamment
des incidents à chicago l'an si vous
voulez bien revenons cette nuit avec le
retour de monsieur madame pompidou à
orly
2h06 ce matin l'appareil présidentiel
s'arrêtaient devant le tapis rouge
déroulé sur l'air d'atterrissage
jusqu'au salon d'honneur quelques
instants plus tard souriant monsieur
pompidou à paris c'est au sommet de la
passerelle suivi de madame pompidou
ils étaient accueillis par monsieur
jacques chaban delmas le premier
ministre une gerbe de roses étaient
remises à madame pompidou et ensemble
ils se dirigèrent vers le salon
d'honneur où se trouvaient tous les
membres du gouvernement
monsieur pompidou serra la main à tous
les ministres il se tourna ensuite vers
les personnalités de l'ambassade des
états unis qui étaient là également pour
l'accueillir à monsieur robert blake
chargé d'affaires des états unis le
président de la république devait dire
comme vous voyez tout va-t-il les
membres du gouvernement faisait ensuite
cercle autour du président pour
recueillir ses impressions
le président pompidou interpellé par les
journalistes faisait la déclaration
suivante voilà de retour et je crois que
chacun comprendra que je réserve et
réflexions et mes impressions pour le
conseil des ministres qui se tiendra
d'ailleurs cet après midi en tout cas je
voudrais simplement que tous les
français tous les français toutes les
françaises
sache que je suis et que nous sommes au
moins aussi satisfait de la façon dont
s'est terminé notre voyage que de la
façon il avait commencé et je crois que
ce que nous avons fait là bas aura bien
servi l'amitié américaine et d'une façon
générale la cause de la paix
le chef de l'état qui regagne aussi tous
les vices
nous en saurons sans doute plus cet
après midi puisque comme le président
pompidou l'a dit aux journalistes à son
arrivée à orly il y a conseil des
ministres exceptionnellement l'après
midi vous le comprendrez facilement à
15h30 donc à l'elysée
mesdames messieurs bonsoir la rédaction
d'antenne 2 vient d'envoyer un message à
jacques fouroux pour toute l'équipe de
france good luck
elle n'aura pas besoin seulement de
chance il faudra du punch de la cohésion
et du courage car demain la bataille de
tous et canam sera vraiment terrible les
français ont bien battu l'autre jour les
gallois au parc des princes mais les
anglais cette année c'est d'autre chose
et alors sur leur terrain
bonjour désignèrent 13h jeu vous laissez
entendre qu'au cours de son intervention
télévisée valéry giscard d'estaing
oublierait pour une fois les gadgets du
style bûche dans la cheminée ou chiens
courants dans le parc de l'élise et
c'est ce que le président de la
république a fait en se présentant
devant les caméras hier dans le décor
traditionnel d adresse aux français un
retour donc à une certaine tradition une
certaine solennité égayer seulement par
un bouquet tricolore une solennité une
gravité souhaitée par le chef de l'état
qui voulait en 26 minutes
faire un constat réaffirmé sa
détermination exprimé sa volonté
expliqué ses objectifs par son attitude
physique valéry giscard d'estaing a sans
doute tenu à redonner à la fonction
présidentielle son éclat et ils ont
aussi une certaine majesté
rien de grand ne se fait sans espérance
disait renan et c'est d'espérance que
valéry giscard d'estaing a voulu parler
hier en rassurant ceux qui lui ont donné
leur confiance les rassurer sur le
devenir de la france les rassurer et
aussi les mobiliser autour de jacques
chirac proclamé officiellement chef et
conducteurs de la majorité
mieux vaut ne pas changer d'attelage au
milieu du gain disait abraham lincoln
l'attelage giscard chirac semble depuis
hier soir un peu plus resserré que
certaines rumeurs ne lui laissait
entendre un attelage de bataille
tirant derrière lui des canons de la
majorité et chacun sait que la
différence entre un bateau et un canon
c'est que le second ne faut ne flotte
pas il tire la cible a été défini à
l'eau si c'est le collectivisme la
distance qui sépare les canons de cette
cible deux années de préparation pour
les élections législatives considérées
par le chef de l'état comme des
élections politiques celles des
municipales ayant été rappelés comme
étant des élections locales
autant dire que de tels propos une telle
résolution ont été accueillis par les
états majors politiques et syndicaux
patrice duhamel par des appréciations
très diverses
en effet si chacun se retrouve pour
reconnaître qu'un changement de ton a
marqué l'intervention de valéry giscard
d'estaing les commentaires divergent
bien sûr sur le fond de la déclaration
du chef de l'état la majorité bien sûr
et très satisfaite l'opposition bien sûr
est déçu quant aux partenaires sociaux
leurs réactions sont mitigées
claude labbé déclare pour lui dr valéry
giscard d'estaing a dit ce que les
français attendaient la mission confiée
à jacques chirac doit mettre fin à un
certain flottement dans la majorité
jacques dominati pour les républicains
indépendants annonce qu'après cette
intervention toutes les énergies seront
mobilisés nous serons ajoutent-ils
disciplinés et enthousiaste car nous
voulons que la politique du président de
la république soit mieux comprise pour
les centristes un commentaires d'andré
diligent l'essentiel est de constater
que malgré certains conseils qu'ils
étaient donnés le président a décidé de
poursuivre l'action pour la réforme
difficile à classer sur l'échiquier
politique parce qu'il souhaite se
trouver ailleurs michel jobert commente
lui l'ancien ministre des finances à
développer dit-il dans l'immobilisme ces
thèmes d'autrefois alors que tout a
changé
mais l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères souhaite quand même bonne
chance au président de la république
dans l'opposition c'est donc la
déception pour jean calas pas du parti
communiste monsieur giscard d'estaing
est obligé de reconnaître que sous son
règne la france souffre avec un
véritable cynisme poursuit jan kana pas
le chef de l'état avoue par ailleurs que
ces prétendues réformes ne sont pour lui
qu'un slogan est une affiche les
radicaux de gauche considèrent que le
chef de l'état n'a pu cacher son
désarroi et qu'il a enterré la société
libérale avancée quant aux socialistes
par la voix de claude estier il affirme
que valéry giscard d'estaing paru mal à
l'aise qu'il ne présente aucun projet
sérieux et qu'il s'efforce de faire
vibrer la corde de la défense de l'ordre
contre les violences quant à monsieur
moussel pour le ps lui il pense que le
président de la république a cherché la
stabilité dans le flottement du côté
syndical des réactions défavorables de
la cgt de la cfdt pour georges séguy
valéry giscard d'estaing était défensif
et peu convaincant la cfdt note que le
chef de l'état a apporté la preuve que
le pouvoir actuel ne pouvait pas
répondre aux aspirations des travail
heures monsieur tessier pour la cftc
regrette qu'il n'y ait rien eu de
concret dans cette intervention pour la
politique familiale et françois bergeron
pour fins ouvrière se félicite de la
volonté du président de la république de
poursuivre la construction européenne
il note toutefois que cette communauté
des neuf doit être davantage soucieuse
de justice sociale
les cards quand on s'interroge sur
l'impact de cette intervention
ils affirment qu'ils jugeront sur des
actes et non sur des intentions et par
exemple à l'occasion des prochaines
discussions qui vont s'ouvrir avec le
premier ministre
du côté patronal enfin une incertitude
et une satisfaction
la certitude est manifestée par léon
gingembre qui dit nous attendions la
paix économique
nous allons rester à nouveau dans une
situation trouble la satisfaction vient
du patronat français qui retient
l'engagement de ne pas affaiblir les
entreprises la conviction qu'il ne faut
pas réformer n'importe quoi et n'importe
comment
l'appel au sens des responsabilités des
français et enfin la définition par le
président de la république d'une
ambition collective pour la france
assurée par le développement économique
du pays son indépendance dans le cadre
de l' or voilà pour les réactions voilà
pour les principales réactions ajoutant
quand même celle du sénateur kay avec
eux nous retrouverons tout à l'heure
puisqu'il tenait une conférence de
presse à laquelle assistaient dominique
laurie sénateurs caillavet qui à
l'occasion de cette conférence de presse
a eu à aussi à se prononcer sur
l'intervention télévisée hier soir du
président de la république une
intervention dans laquelle le sénateur
caillavet regrette en particulier la
nomination de jacques chirac comme
leader ou comme je le disais attaquant
de la majorité il trouve en effet que
jacques chirac risque de bloquer le
système de l'ouverture mais nous
reviendrons aux propos tenus ce matin
par le sénateur caillavet dans un
instant en compagnie de michel denisot
avec qui nous allons voir l'essentiel de
l'actualité
tf1 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
30 des 60 otages de l'ambassade
américaine de téhéran signent une
pétition pour implorer l'extradition du
shah seuls admis à l'inhumation de
madame de gaulle sa famille et quelques
personnalités gaulliste
le film le pull-over rouge la cour
d'appel de paris ordonne la suppression
de quatre séquences qui portait atteinte
à la vie privée
un succès pour l'aérospatiale
hélicoptères français twinstar déjà
vendu à 180 exemplaires avant même la
fin de tous les essais madame
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir monsieur
yasser arafat a confirmé aujourd'hui que
l'ol paie l'organisation de libération
de la palestine devraient par tous les
moyens en faveur de la libération des
otages américains retenus à téhéran le
président de l'ol paie a donné ces
précisions à beyrouth au chargé
d'affaires de l'ambassade du maroc le
roi hassan ii était en effet intervenu
auprès de l'ol paie afin que les otages
américains détenus à téhéran soient
libérés l'organisation de libération de
la palestine entretient en effet
d'excellents rapports avec le nouveau
gouvernement iraniens et en particulier
avec celui de lier avec l'ayatollah
khomeini mais pour l'instant la
soixantaine d'otages est toujours entre
les mains des étudiants islamiques sur
place le point avec notre envoyé spécial
thierry de scitivaux
bonsoir au temps suspends ton vol après
l'heure c'est plus l'heure avant l'heure
c'est pas l'heure
qui veut voyager loin ménage sa montre
bien entendu tout le week-end
l'actualité sera branché sur le cadran
électrique ou non qui vous fera vivre
dimanche une journée de 23 heures mais
qui finalement ne gagnera pas grand
chose sur le temps que nous avons à
vivre ni sur ce que nous faisons du
temps que nous vivons
la raison de ce retour à une vieille
tradition l'heure d'été une tradition
qui n'évoque pas forcément de bons
souvenirs
et bien c'est de mettre nos horloges à
l'heure du soleil pour faire quelques
économies d'énergie et sur ce point il
faut quand même prendre en considération
le scepticisme de l'edf
elle n'attend pas une vraie baisse de la
consommation d'ailleurs c'est vrai que
si on en est aux économies de bouts de
chandelles sur l'énergie il faudrait
expliquer à un certain nombre de
citoyens pourquoi les éclairages publics
restent parfois allumés en plein jour
mais ceci est une autre histoire
que va-t-il se passer en fête dimanche
quand vous dormirez à une heure du matin
il sera brusquement deux heures du matin
si vous regardez votre montre en dormant
vous aurez perdu une heure de sommeil et
si vous ne la regardez pas ce sera comme
d'habitude ni plus ni moins quand on
essaie de m'expliquer ça à moi c'est un
peu comme quand on veut me faire
comprendre les liens de parenté entre la
petite cousine de la nièce de la tante
berthe et l'oncle du cousin isidore qui
s'était marié en secondes noces avec le
troisième enfant né d'un troisième lit
de la grand mère du premier nommé je n'y
comprends rien ce que je vois bien c'est
que le changement d'heure va poser des
problèmes à la sncf à l'aviation aux
transports en général et surtout surtout
aux travailleurs frontaliers
nous aurons l'occasion de vous préciser
ces problèmes pendant le week-end
puisque l'équipe de thierry de scitivaux
à préparer là dessus un certain nombre
de reportages
en attendant il n'est pas question de
vous laisser sur mon incompétence
françois de closets va d'abord vous dire
le pourquoi de ce changement d'heure
dimanche et les vraies économies
d'énergie qu'on peut en attendre
michel chevalet vous proposera ensuite
d'un coup d'oeil 1 les conséquences de
ce changement notamment pour nous la
télévision
rami
principes en matière d'énergie une
économie est aussi intéressante qu'une
production
deuxième principe ce sont les petites
économies qui font les grandes pour
faire marcher ses automobiles la france
doit importer environ 20 millions de
tonnes de pétrole chaque année si l'on
découvrait demain en france un gisement
capable de produire ces deux millions de
tonnes par an on importerait plus que 18
millions de tonnes par exemple pour cet
usage chaque année mais si l'on amélioré
de 10 % le rendement des moteurs
automobiles
le résultat serait exactement le même
puisqu'il suffirait d'importer 18
millions de tonnes de pétrole par an
pour la circulation dans ce cas précis
bien sûr il faudrait d'effectuer des
recherches et transformer les moteurs
automobiles
cela coûterait de l'argent mais depuis
que le pétrole est cher
de nombreuses économies sont devenues
rentables avant la crise quand on ne
parlait pas d'économie on avait prévu
que la france consommerait l'équivalent
de 285 millions de tonnes de pétrole par
an en 1985 il est prévu que cette
consommation ne dépassera pas 2 140
millions de tonnes
c'est dire que l'on compte produire
l'équivalent de 45 millions de tonnes
d'économies chaque année dans une
dizaine d'années et dès 1975 ces
économies ont atteint 15 millions de
tonnes
cela bien sûr sans imposer des
restrictions intolérable où trouver ces
économies les gros filon ont vite été
repéré le chauffage par exemple un degré
de moins 4 millions de tonnes de fuel
économiser mais pour la suite
il faut viser des économies qui se
chiffrent en milliers et plus en
millions de tonnes cette semaine même
les cimentiers se sont engagés à
transformer leurs procédés afin
d'économiser 400 mille tonnes de pétrole
par an dans une dizaine d'années se
mettre à l'heure d'été permettra
d'économiser de l'éclairage cela ferait
gagner au maximum 300 milliers de tonnes
de pétrole par an économie modeste mais
gratuite et
quand on n'a pas de pétrole il ne faut
négliger aucune idée si midi devient une
heure les trains partiront toujours à
l'heure à l'heure de votre montre donc
de ce côté là aucun changement
simplement quelques problèmes pour la
sncf dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
les trains partis samedi à l'heure
arriveront donc en retard dimanche matin
par contre c'est du côté de l'étranger
du côté des frontières que les choses
sont plus épineuse puisque les trains
changent rondeurs en passant la
frontière alors renseignez vous de même
air france a dû résoudre quelques castex
d'horaires par exemple paris new york de
13 heures partira à 13h30 et le new york
paris a tendu à orly se posera à roissy
motif l'aéroport d'orly est fermée au
trafic à partir de 11 heures le soir
enfin les télévisions vont avoir
quelques problèmes par exemple nous qui
recevons d'habitude à midi les images en
provenance de l'étranger images que nous
vous présentons dans le journal d'yves
mourousi et bien ces images tomberont en
plein journal
et de fait nous risquons de ne pas
pouvoir vous les présenter en direct
enfin les journaux des télévisions
étrangères vont se placer au moment du
film sur la première et la deuxième
chaîne du coup télé luxembourg a avancé
son journal d'une demi-heure de façon à
ce qu'il apparaisse en même temps que le
nôtre
comme quoi économie ou pas concurrence
oblige
oui et puis à des problèmes des changes
internationaux au point de vue images
qui ne nous avantage pas nous télévision
bien cela dit ne manifestons pas une
mauvaise humeur ou une mauvaise foi tout
à fait inutile à propos de ce changement
d'heure beaucoup diront les avantages de
leurs du soleil comme pendant mon
enfance en bretagne
et surtout il apparaît clairement que
les ouvriers les employés qui rentrent
chez eux
bref tous les gens au travail pourront
profiter des longues soirées d'été
notamment pour faire du sport ah voilà
un avantage en effet